(audience applauding)
- My next guest grew up
in Ireland and fell in love
with fashion at a very young age.
But at three foot five
clothes from pages of Vogue
were not exactly meant
for someone her size.
So she set out to change that.
She started a blog
which led to a TED talk,
which then led to rubbing elbows
with everyone from
Oprah to Kim Kardashian.
Her message is simple,
"The world should be
designed for everyone."
(audience applauding)
Activist, author, educator
and podcaster, Sinead Burke yeah.
So you look cute and all those
little lips and lipstick,
I love that, all of it.
- Thank you.
- So your family played a pretty big part
in your activism, Correct?
- Yeah, well firstly, this is product.
(interviewer and audience laughing)
But secondly--
- Not pro doe' which you can get
- on another Street
- I know..
But yeah, if I'm in any way a success,
it's because I'm a love child.
And I grew up with this
very visceral understanding
of I could do whatever
it is that I wanted.
So in my family, I'm the
oldest of five children.
I have three sisters and one brother,
all of whom are average height
like everybody else on the sofa.
But my dad is a little
person, just like me.
And growing up and having
somebody there who looked
so much like me really
underlying this thing that,
anything was possible,
because my dad survived
and thrived and he was just
this amazing individual
who always said that I could do
whatever and I always
wanted to be a teacher.
I started out my career as
an elementary school teacher.
And while I was in
university, we started a blog.
And the idea of it was that as a teacher,
you would write this blog
because when your kids come home
from school, you say to them,
"what did you do today?"
And your child says, "nothing."
- Exactly a girl,
- But as somebody who knows--
- I'm like, "what is she doing all day?"
She never tells me.
- And the lecture and
surprises that you can write
about anything you want in this blog.
So I wrote about Cate Blanchett
wearing javante contort to the Oscars.
because I had always this
innate interest in fashion
because as somebody who
was a disabled woman,
if I sit across from you
in a product SO Dress
that's from a recent collection,
you're like, "Oh, she's interesting."
And yet, fashion was never
considerate of people like me.
As the eldest of all of my sisters,
I would bring them shopping,
they would pick up a pair
of high heels in the store,
and I would try and wear them too.
And they were like, "no,
this doesn't fit you."
And I remember just
thinking this was so unjust,
not only because I was more
interested in the industry,
but because we legally
each have to wear clothes.
And if this is something that we all have
to subscribe to,
- Not in some states.
(everyone laughing)
- Thankfully amolish.
But why do we not all get to participate
because it's part of our
identity, it touches our skin.
So this blog that evolved today
I'm getting to do a TED talk
to talk about why design should
be inclusive for everybody.
That it wasn't just
something that was facetious
but it could change the world.
And from that, got to
be on the cover of Vogue
and go to the metal I mean, it's wild.
- And I love that I found
out you were the first
little person ever got to
go to the Met Gala, right?
- Yeah.
- That ever attended
and going to the carpet.
How was that like?
I've never been.
- An absolutely terrifying.
(everyone laughing)
- They're all yelling at you,
like on the car?(laughing)
- It's so nerve wracking.
But it was this extraordinary
thing where nobody
had ever been there, who
looked like me before.
And if you can't see it, you can't be it.
And for me, you woke up 23 steps,
it was talking about Anna Wintour,
who's the editor and
chief of American Vogue,
talking to her about
accessibility at the Met Galla.
What does it look like
when we take an institution
like the Met, and make
it open to everyone?
So the Met Gala is an event
that happens once a year.
It's a fundraiser for the
fashion department in the museum.
And it is anybody who we
think we should be listening
to in the world, in many
ways are probably invited.
And the tickets are ludicrously expensive.
I went with a brand like Gucci
and Anna Wintour ticks off
everybody who gets to go.
And to be there, I felt
a sense of pressure that,
whether I liked it or not,
despite only being able
to speak for myself,
I was representing not just
people who look like me,
but people with disabilities in general.
Because so often they're just
not part of our conversation.
Even when we talk about
inclusion and diversity,
disability is not even
something or word that we use.
- Because if people
aren't directly impacted
by it on an everyday basis,
it's not even the forefront of their mind.
- It's not something we
think of and that ignorance
is often not malicious,
but that's not an excuse
for us not to be facilitating
the conversation.
So where you go to
something like the Met Gala,
and you get to wear this magnificent dress
that's now on display in the
Gucci Garden and Florence,
what does the person who
sees that, sitting at home,
scrolling through Twitter and Instagram,
what do they now think
is possible for them?
And how long does it take
before the next little person
gets to go to the Met Galla?
I hope it's this year.
- So how have you carried
this message though,
to so many powerful people?
Did you just walk up?
I go to events, I've been in this industry
for nearly 20 years and I
still don't talk to people.
I'm like, I ain't gonna
talk unless spoken to.
Unless that freak Meryl
Streep at once, but--
(audience laughing)
Hey yeah.
but I'm just saying that's
bold, just to walk up to people.
- I live in a body where people are unsure
so often how to interact with me.
And that discomfort can
sometimes bring about an apathy
and a conversation doesn't occur.
So since I've been very, very young,
I've had to step into it and be proud
of the body that I live in.
And yeah, I've walked up to Anna Wintour
and the people I admire most, I'm like,
"Hi, I'm Sinead, I think
your work is incredible.
"I think we should have a conversation,
"and I think we should talk
about design more broadly."
And in many ways, that's
probably what allows me
to do something like be a podcast host.
I have a show called As Me with Sinead,
and I asked four questions
to every single guest,
including Jamie Lee Curtis,
Victoria Beckham, Dan Levy
and one of the questions I ask is,
what's it like to live in your body?
Because my experience is so explicit?
Well, most of the time, I
forget that I'm a little person
until I can't reach
something or I'm reminded,
and I think that's all of us.
And what's the potential when we realize
that so many of our challenges
are not in isolation?
Like we all struggle.
We all feel alone, we all
feel like we can't do things
or not represented and what happens
when we realize that,
so it is Kelly Clarkson,
so it is Paul Wesley,
so it is Lilly Singh,
you're like, "oh, if they
can do it, why not me?"
- I mean--
(audience applauding)
I love you.
I just...
I love when...
I think what I love most is,
I mean I grew up in church
I just love hearing people preach and talk
and live something that
they're very passionate about
and they're very into and they're
so eloquently spoken at it as well,
- it's so cool,
- Thank you.
it's just inspiring and As
Me with Sinead is available
to download wherever
you can get your podcast
and I am so into it, like
I'm in love with you.
I think you're just such a great person,
you're speaking to like,
not only little people,
you're speaking to the world
in a sense of breaking down
those barriers and I love
that, I think it's really...
we need to stop living in
fear and I agree with you.
so thank ypu for that message, but